Blake Shelton Gwen Stefani's adorable
aesthetic cannot be beat with the two
going head-to-head once again in Season
22 of the voice yeah but they are
definitely putting their marriage to the
test as their friendly competition took
turned during Monday's episode when Gwen
couldn't help but gush over team Legend
singer David Andrew leaving Blake and
well if you got a little jealous
[Applause]
[Music]
think
[Applause]
[Music]
of me
yeah
David you know I wanted you bad
I bought for you I turned for you your
voice is so pretty it's very beautiful
when it came in I was like ah and
besides your voice the way you look your
hair your mustache your oh my God you're
late I know I'm saying like
he's got Style thank you so much you
deserve to have the hype that we're all
giving you because it was so good you
see Blake he's like Dad oh I know I like
it all right now despite Gwen's minor
Crush there's no trouble in Paradise
here as Blake was caught on camera
complimenting his wife
every season in the battle rounds you
never know what's going to happen look
how pretty you are I am thank you oh
I know that probably sounds like
scripted like I am thank you but like I
get the sense that is the window into
their relationship it is so nice when
your partner says you look nice like
it's such a simple thing Kevin if you're
listening it's not hard you can just say
why can't you be more like Blake just
like once a weekend that's it once a
week all right Blake and Gwen's adorable
moments have been front and center this
season last week fans were feeling the
love between the couple after a duet
between contestants Ava in Orlando
reminded Gwen of her Blake
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow that was exciting I was sitting here
thinking is that what me and you look
like when we sing together
in my mind we do
that's amazing I love them we're just
saying it's amazing I find it so amazing
when people can sing that way like that
comes out of your mouth it is I have to
watch the boys I haven't watched enough
of it this season yeah but I love it I
know and I love that Gwen of Lake really
play up not just their relationship but
they're doing so well I mean they've
even said off the top you know when they
first met they didn't really think this
was gonna last they were both coming out
of divorces and then here we are how
many years later and they're cuter than
ever I love them